[SPEAKER_00]: [Automatic captions by Autotekst using OpenAI Whisper V3. May contain recognition errors.] The Ozone photon was coming and then they started to win every competition.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I said, OK, we have to do something. So this is how the GTO3 was born. How's your relationship with Ozone, guys?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's still, there's a chance to develop more performance. But in the same time, the key of success today, Paraglider, is... Please tell
[SPEAKER_00]: us about Boom 13. Without letting out any secrets.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is up everyone? Welcome back to another episode of Panic Lightning Athletes Podcast. I'm your host Anindya Singh and as usual we are coming
[SPEAKER_01]: to you deferred live but exclusive from the Macedonian town of Krasavo, the racing capital of the world. And today I have another very special
[SPEAKER_01]: guest joining us this time around. A lot of you know him, a lot of you have followed his passion for quite a long time, and most importantly, a lot
[SPEAKER_01]: of you have experienced the art of flight and all the joy that comes with it because of this person. I'm talking about none other than the man
[SPEAKER_01]: himself, the force behind Jinn paragliders, Mr. Jinn. Hello, nice to see you. This is such a big honor. Thank you so much for coming. Oh, my
[SPEAKER_00]: pleasure. Mr. Jim, you happen to be one of the very few founders of a brand who is still flying a paraglider, and not just flying it, who is also
[SPEAKER_01]: racing his own creations at the very top level. I have a question, sir. How do you feel? Oh, yeah. I've been flying since 1977, so I'm quite old.
[SPEAKER_00]: But...
[SPEAKER_00]: Flying is like my life. So it doesn't really see the differences from the beginning to today. For me, the flying is just the joy of life and things
[SPEAKER_00]: like this. So I still fly almost every day. Usually I'm testing the wings with my test pilot. And I design the wings and I fly, I feel it change. So
[SPEAKER_00]: actually the flying is my daily job. So when I test the wings, we have test also full speed performance. So we are, I'm the full speed is, I don't
[SPEAKER_00]: need a training period. I'm almost every single days we do the comparison, full speed, whatever. That's why I still can compete in the
[SPEAKER_00]: competition with the World Cup young boys. So I don't need to win. But it's a pleasure to fly with this. And then also in the same time, I also
[SPEAKER_00]: compare my new wings to see in the real competition. This is how I fly in the steel competition now. Mr. Jin, there's a saying called that there
[SPEAKER_01]: are no old and bold pilots. But are you challenging that saying since a long time? Because I see you pushing full bar, being the lead guy or the
[SPEAKER_01]: first transition. So is this an old and bold pilot that we are looking at?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just, it's like a habit. When you fly long time in the competition, it's usually you push the bar and then just do it. So I don't see why I don't have
[SPEAKER_00]: to do. No, I love it. I love it that you still have the passion and all the courage. Do you have any idea about the amount of hours that you might
[SPEAKER_01]: have accumulated? Just a rough number. Are you at 10,000 plus or less? What do you mean? Total? Indeed. Yeah. Ever since you first picked up a
[SPEAKER_01]: glider. I don't know. I never count my hours flying. But I've been flying since hang gliding. So I do a lot of hang gliding competition too. So
[SPEAKER_00]: after I changed paragliding and paragliding competition, And paragliding is like my daily job, testing. Whenever the weather is
[SPEAKER_00]: good, then we are on the hills to fly, testing, top landing, changing. So usually per day, in a good day, I am like four or five hours in the air. So
[SPEAKER_00]: it's a lot. Yeah. The reason why I ask this is because there's a theory which says if you do something for 10,000 hours, you become natural at
[SPEAKER_01]: it. So it seems that you and your team are close to anybody who flies for six, five, six decades. I think that is the amount of time. If you say 70s,
[SPEAKER_01]: you have been flying and now we're in 20, half of the second decade of this millennia, then probably it's almost like five, 55 or 60 years that you
[SPEAKER_01]: have been in the game. Yeah, almost 50 years since 77, so we are in 25, so it's almost 48 years, 47 years, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm the only one in my place in Korea. All my flying, hang gliding friends, they stopped flying since long time ago. But I think I'm the
[SPEAKER_00]: only one who still fly today. It's such a big inspiration that there is somebody having the passion, the courage, the time, money, and the
[SPEAKER_01]: energy. And most importantly, stayed safe all throughout. I think that itself is a podium or a medal in itself. Like staying safe to practice it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah. Could you tell us a little bit about origins of flying in South Korea? How was it? What was the history of free flying in your
[SPEAKER_01]: country when you got into it? When I began hang gliding, it was very beginning of hang glider. So this hang glider was never able to do any
[SPEAKER_00]: cross-country flying. You take off landing with the Rogallo. I don't know if you know that. Just very basic hang glider and beginning of hang
[SPEAKER_00]: glider. You just take off and go land in one minute. But that was big pleasure. And then when paragliding start, There's not many place to
[SPEAKER_00]: fly in Korea because all the mountains was no road and things like this. But we found a new place and we speak with the local government and put the
[SPEAKER_00]: new road and kind of thing. So I did a lot of open the flying site to the city hall or local government. And then also in the very beginning of
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliding, I was young and I had a strong passion. So I had a big school. Yeah. So I think that was, I don't know how this energy came from, but I do
[SPEAKER_00]: 24 hours work almost, and then teaching the peoples and like, they have no idea, so. I have a lot of experience from hang gliding, so I know what
[SPEAKER_00]: you have to do in the air. So when paragliding was begun, I knew the air, I knew how to thermaling, but by then, actually the paraglider was almost
[SPEAKER_00]: similar to parachute, so it was never possible to any cross-country flying. So then slowly the paraglider developed and then start to make a
[SPEAKER_00]: distance flying kind of thing. So why I was fully concentrated paragliding in Korea was in Korea there's not many place to land.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's lots of power lines. Korea is a small, tiny country. Actually, I like Korea. paraglider where you can land anywhere. You don't need a lot
[SPEAKER_00]: of big space to land like hang gliding. So that's why I was really pushing the paragliding sports in Korea. So now the level of Korean pilots are
[SPEAKER_00]: really good. Some of them is like world-class pilot. So I'm happy to see today the young guys doing good in the world clubs and international
[SPEAKER_00]: competition. So I'm quite happy. And I did a quite big job in Korea. That's so nice to hear that you basically mentored the community in a way
[SPEAKER_01]: which is reaping the benefits.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell us a little bit about the origins of your brand. When did the idea from a pilot to a brand owner come into your life? Actually, I was working
[SPEAKER_00]: for some other brand called Edel. And then Edel was a big company, but they didn't have a designer. So they just, anyhow, they made something.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so then I joined and I made this Edel number one in the world. So this Edel was very big. and huge communities and World Cups. So many people
[SPEAKER_00]: fly air gliders and then somehow in 1997, somehow it was time to leave. So I didn't want to start my company. I want to, actually I wanted to take a
[SPEAKER_00]: break. But somehow, somebody's asking me to have competition wings. I had the time, so I drew the gliders. And then I asked some small factory to
[SPEAKER_00]: stitch and then send it to Japan. And this Japanese guy went to the World Cup with this wing. And they start to go on the podium. It was, for
[SPEAKER_00]: Europeans, in the World Cup, it was a big shock because none of the Asians was on the podium ever. But with the strange win, they start to go on the
[SPEAKER_00]: podium. And it was a big shock in the World Cups. What the hell is this? Who's this newcomer with all the new technologies? So then I told them,
[SPEAKER_00]: don't say this is designed by Jin. Just name it Boomerang. So this Boomerang was going, three of them, Japanese guys, start to go World Cup
[SPEAKER_00]: and then they start to win all in top three. Wow. So then big pilot like Hans Bollinger, Jimmy Parker, by the time they were the top pilot, the
[SPEAKER_00]: world champion, and all these kind of guys are calling. They finally, they knew that it was from Jin. And then they call me, say, I come to Korea
[SPEAKER_00]: tomorrow. Okay. And then we discuss and okay, okay. Then I had to build a small company called Gene Gliders. And then I didn't have other models,
[SPEAKER_00]: only boomerangs. So you started with triple Cs. Yes. So it was funny. Then boomerang was winning. It was booming across. Yes. This is how the
[SPEAKER_00]: Gene Glider was born. That's so interesting. Okay, how did, like, was Ozone not existing at that time? Or what was your biggest competition to
[SPEAKER_01]: the boomerang at that time? The Ozone was starting the nearly same time as Jingle Riders, because the Robbie Whittle, who was one of my test
[SPEAKER_00]: pilot before, and Robbie Whittle is a world champion of hang gliding and world champion of paragliding, and he was working for me as test pilot.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then he start Ozone and I start Jingle Adders. And Ozone was not my competitors. By then, the competitors was like Advanced and Nova. Who
[SPEAKER_00]: else? Yeah. There were... Swing was not too much. So... The advance was good. They have a good team. So they had a nice wing for the competitions.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we have a good model, too. So, yeah, it's nearly the same time Ozone started. Until 2009, Ozone was okay. There's a brand. But none of them
[SPEAKER_00]: was winning any competition. But 2009, in the Super Final World Cup in Italy, Poggio Bostone, We had a full team, boomerang team. And then the
[SPEAKER_00]: Ozone came with a two-liner. Ah, right. Charles Kazoo and Russell Wooden coming, and then they win fourth, second. And from third to 11th
[SPEAKER_00]: was boomerangs. I was... Big news. Then, 2010, you see everywhere ozone. One day to next days, you see. It was a big evolution. So since then
[SPEAKER_00]: ozone take the top and they are still there. So basically the two-liner tech is what propelled the ozone to the podiums. Yes. Mr. Jin, I have a
[SPEAKER_01]: question when it comes to designing. What is the difference which makes one brand better than the others? Because let's say when you came out
[SPEAKER_01]: with Boomerang in the beginning, The other brands also were designing really good gliders, which were being trusted all across the world. And
[SPEAKER_01]: today, when Ozone is designing two-liners which are winning, the other brands are also designing two-liners that are winning. But at that
[SPEAKER_01]: time, boomerang technology was dominating, and now ENZO technology is dominating. So what is it that makes a glider better than the other
[SPEAKER_01]: brand? According to a designer's perspective. I think the success of Boomerang was not only performance, but also safe, easy to fly. That was
[SPEAKER_00]: the key. So there was some glider could maybe have more performance, but in what I say is overall performance. Means when the glider is easy to
[SPEAKER_00]: handle, then you perform better. The success of the ANGEL 3 also in the beginning was not. But today, they really make the wing more easy, safe,
[SPEAKER_00]: stable in full bar, that kind of thing. So people have confidence. The pilots are not stupid. They know if I take this wing, It's easy. So today
[SPEAKER_00]: the whole community, not like it was 20 years ago, today's Facebook, Instagram is for everywhere. Information spreads very fast, yeah. I
[SPEAKER_00]: think the key of success is not only performance, but also success. how easy to handle in full speed during the race. If you get collapsed, what
[SPEAKER_00]: happens? That's very important. So I think that many other brands don't even attempt to design these two-liner competition wings. Actually,
[SPEAKER_00]: the market Looks big to like a composition model, but we don't really make money out of the composition wings. You sell A, B, C gliders are
[SPEAKER_00]: really the main business. Probably they make good money from industry because whole world, there's so many industry here. I think when it
[SPEAKER_01]: comes to R&D, researching and developing, JIN has been at the forefront of R&D for quite a long time. So what was your idea when you set up the JIN
[SPEAKER_01]: company? How did you want to do the research and the development in your company? Did you hire some people or did you just focus everything
[SPEAKER_01]: within you or did you look for support? What was the idea behind? In the beginning... Honestly, none of the designers had the experience like
[SPEAKER_00]: Eugene. All the brands, when I look at the designers, they are starting with paragliding. And I was flying from hang gliding, actually, so I
[SPEAKER_00]: have more experience. understanding about flying and skills and so when I design and testing wings and I know what the air is doing and
[SPEAKER_00]: turbulence and whatever so that was the big difference from the beginning when I designed some wing and finished product then my wing
[SPEAKER_00]: was selling better than the others because it flies better they It glides better, whatever. So that was my success in the beginning. And
[SPEAKER_00]: then we really had a huge team. Because when you have so many competition pilots, you are getting so much feedback. Then after, you can
[SPEAKER_00]: understand what to design. So this was the big community, and this big community was helping me to design the wings better. Same like now,
[SPEAKER_00]: angel, have so many pilot fly angels, and they have entire informations coming to them, and they know what to change. So this was same thing
[SPEAKER_00]: happened in Jin before. So then today, my experience was good, but then Since 10 years ago, what's important is it's not only experience. The
[SPEAKER_00]: real research was actually needed. So start to work with the R&D, with the university, research. So we start, since last 10 years ago, we start
[SPEAKER_00]: to develop the paragliders. But any university, they are good at airplanes, but they didn't understand paragliders. None of them was
[SPEAKER_00]: able to help. But I found one good one, and this guy was a student, but then he become a professor, and then he start to help me. to develop the
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliding wings. So today we have a big support by the government. So last time when we designed Wave Leading Edge, we get $1 million support
[SPEAKER_00]: by the government to work with this university. So we spent $1 million to finish the formula of this Wave Leading Edge. That is unbelievable.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're so telling me that there was administration ready to spend a million dollars on our sport. This is Korean government was helping the
[SPEAKER_00]: small company like Gingliders and then collaboration with the university. So this lab was really interesting to work together
[SPEAKER_00]: because they start to understand the slow wings like paragliders. So this is how the Waverly DH was born. And today we have an even bigger
[SPEAKER_00]: amount of the budget, $2 million for four years. So we are now studying about the wing shapes, wing tips, whatever. This is exciting. It will
[SPEAKER_00]: come soon. But you need the money. What I want to say is that you really need to calculate and test and things like this. I don't really use the
[SPEAKER_00]: CFD. CFD result is computing. You can use it as a... CFD is a computing program. Okay, fluid dynamics. Yes, yes. Software. Yes, software.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then you can take it as a reference. But we do more in the wind tunnel test. The wind tunnel test is actually you get the real, more practical data.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm quite happy that we are working with this lab. That's nice. I think, are you the only brand who has wind tunnel accessibility?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I have never seen any other brand. I heard some companies have small wind tunnels in the company, but... We are working with the
[SPEAKER_00]: university who has the wind tunnels, so it's interesting to see the wind tunnel test result. It's very practical. Mr. Jin, it inspires me how you
[SPEAKER_01]: challenge the status quo time to time, be it with the original Boomerang back in the day or be it with GTO3. Now, GTO3 is a wing that I'm very curious
[SPEAKER_01]: about because it seems to be the racehorse of Jin brand right now. Coming up, all the SRS comps, the pilots are trusting us, the community is happy
[SPEAKER_01]: with it. The full bar performance is pretty amazing, but I believe you developed Boomerang earlier than GTO3. Could you please tell us a
[SPEAKER_01]: little bit about the technology that this two-liner ENC has, and how is it becoming the status quo of the SRS and two-liner series? We learn a lot
[SPEAKER_00]: from the two-liner competition wings and bring it down to the C-class. Because in the beginning, the two-liner was, the image of two-liner was
[SPEAKER_00]: dangerous, more difficult, and things like that. But then when this knowledge, two-liner, I mean, for us, also we made a lot of mistakes, for
[SPEAKER_00]: sure, try and errors. And then we learn more and more. So then today we can, like boomerang 12, for example, super easy, nice handling, safe.
[SPEAKER_00]: After huge collapse, the glider never rotates. There's no big energy to turn or whatever. So it's safe wings. So we learn. And because we did a lot
[SPEAKER_00]: of experience and we have this wave leading edge and whatever. So then after we really want to, when the C class accepted by EN with the folding
[SPEAKER_00]: lines, Then we started to develop the two-liner sea gliders because we know two-liner is easy to fly and also you can really enjoy the speed,
[SPEAKER_00]: cross-country flying. But it took some time to make. When I designed the Bonanza 3 two-liner sea, There was no SRS in competition, so I make
[SPEAKER_00]: bonanza 3 purely for cross-country, safe. When you do the cross-country, let's say in the Alps, For example, then you're going to
[SPEAKER_00]: fly sometimes the lee side, because you fly seven, eight hours, nine hours, and for sure you will go to the lee side a few times. Then there's a
[SPEAKER_00]: lot of turbulence. So my focus was to make the wing very stable. instead of very high speed or high performance. So good enough for
[SPEAKER_00]: cross-country flying. Then after Bonanza 3, the SRS start. So then again, the Ozone photon was coming and then they start to win every
[SPEAKER_00]: competition. And I say, okay, we have to do something. So this is how the GTO 3 was born. How's your relationship with those old guys? Oh, nothing
[SPEAKER_00]: wrong. I have a good relation with Luca Mons. It's so nice to hear. There's a healthy competition. And I think healthy competition is
[SPEAKER_01]: essential in any community to go in the right direction. Because, of course, dominance of one brand is very good for them. The
[SPEAKER_01]: monopolization is never good for the industry as a whole. So I think with GTO3 coming in and challenging photon dominance, it's just so nice to
[SPEAKER_01]: see as a pilot, as a consumer, that there are more choices to pick up from. Let's talk a little bit about wave leading. You released a video about
[SPEAKER_01]: this R&D that has gone in. It said it has influenced a little bit from the whale fin design, animal whale fin. Tell me, what were the origins of
[SPEAKER_01]: this idea? How did this come to be? This technology has been in the industry since a long time, actually. And this back whale has a big...
[SPEAKER_00]: how we call it, fins, and then they have these tubercles. And these tubercles, a lot of scientists study about why they have such huge
[SPEAKER_00]: whales as these tubercles. Then they found the tubercle is walking and reaches the tracks. So they are using these tubercles in some kind of
[SPEAKER_00]: fence or... Even in the airplanes. In the airplanes? Yes. Where? In the small airplanes. Oh, really? So when I get this proposal by the
[SPEAKER_00]: professor, then I said, okay, let's try. So this university professor, he was very keen to develop It's a cubicle on Paragliders. So this is how I
[SPEAKER_00]: begin with this $1 million fund. We asked the government, we apply this project, then government to check and then they said, okay, it's
[SPEAKER_00]: interesting. So they pay $1 million. So we had the money to develop this Wave of Leading Edge. We named it Wave of Leading Edge. But it's actually
[SPEAKER_00]: called the tubercles.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is how we, in the beginning, we made a few mistakes. We put everywhere the tubercles from the entire wingspan. Then the glide
[SPEAKER_00]: performance was good, but then the wing was spinning very early. and the stalls on the wingtips very quick. And so professor, I asked him, this is
[SPEAKER_00]: not good. Then he discovered that normally the rails has a straight, wing, and then it has tubercles. But our paraglider has a curvature. The
[SPEAKER_00]: wind flow is different. So then we discovered that 60% of the wing span, we put the tubercles, and then the wing tip is normally leading it. So
[SPEAKER_00]: then this was working perfectly, no stolen wing tips, because we need all the lift and performance in the middle. And the tips are reducing
[SPEAKER_00]: drags. Usually when submarine-style harnesses, cocoon-style harnesses came, the logic that was given was that the fluid, in this case
[SPEAKER_01]: air, flows better on smooth surfaces because there's less drag, there is easier flow of the wind. Tubicles make the surface a little bit
[SPEAKER_01]: rough-pitched, I would say. Do we see tubicle design coming to the harnesses as well in time to come, or is it just the wings that can benefit
[SPEAKER_01]: from this now? I don't think Kubrick could unharness I don't think so. Because I'm talking, let's say, the golf ball analogy. Like, golf ball
[SPEAKER_01]: isn't completely smooth. It has small dimples. Dimples, yeah. Which help it cut through the air in a much more efficient manner. So it is
[SPEAKER_01]: similar to the typical design. Not exactly the same, but it attacks the same level of physics. So do we see something changing in these super
[SPEAKER_01]: smooth cocoon-style harnesses that we have in time to come as well? If you find these dimple fabrics, for sure it will work. And we were already
[SPEAKER_00]: discussing about these matters. But today, what's urgently needed is today. With already these submarine harness types, is already there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, if you can reduce this arm where you are at full speed, you have to hold the bee and you always walk. So your hands, this is a huge drag
[SPEAKER_00]: actually. So if you can reduce this arm's drag while you are at full speed, this will be happening soon. Are we seeing that rake handles
[SPEAKER_01]: being controlled from into the cocoon at some point in time? No, I don't think so. It's very dangerous. It reacts very slow. Some brands want to
[SPEAKER_00]: do the arms going down. Like a closed canopy is what my question was. Are we looking at paralleling going into closed canopies eventually in
[SPEAKER_01]: time to come? What do you mean closed canopies? Something which has a covering over the pilot's head as well, right? Now we are just covered up
[SPEAKER_00]: to the chest. Oh, okay. You mean the cockpit completely, like the sailplane. Correct, correct. One day, some other, maybe some brand
[SPEAKER_00]: will develop it. Yeah. I quickly want to touch upon the topic, Mr. Jin, about performance versus price optimization. A million dollars is a
[SPEAKER_01]: huge blessing in any company's R&D. Paragliding itself is an expensive sport. The customers obviously complain about money all the time, that
[SPEAKER_01]: the gear is getting expensive. The manufacturers say that the raw materials are getting expensive, and the yarn makers and the ones who
[SPEAKER_01]: supply raw materials are saying they're doing the best they can. When it comes to making performance, is cost a big factor which holds back
[SPEAKER_01]: performance? If somebody comes out and says that, all right, I will set aside 10 million or 15 million, then can we see super performing
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliders? I think it's still that there is a chance to develop more performance. But in the same time, the key of success today,
[SPEAKER_00]: paraglider, is safety. And we increase the performance a lot, but in the same time, the wing is safer and easier to fly compared to 20 years ago, 30
[SPEAKER_00]: years ago. Today, the technology's developed in a very super good way. All the pilots, they don't feel it, but Before, when it's very strong
[SPEAKER_00]: condition, you wouldn't fly because too turbulence. But today, like yesterday, so strong wind, nothing happened because it was easy and
[SPEAKER_00]: stable. So that's the benefit of paragliders. And so I think the... We're always concerned about performance, but in the same time, how
[SPEAKER_00]: easy you can handle and how stable and you feel comfortable in the air. That's very important for the market. Okay, tell me a little bit about
[SPEAKER_01]: safety. What defines paraglider safety? Because we keep on moving slowly towards less collapsible wings, like the ones which are harder
[SPEAKER_01]: to collapse. And we have technologies like RAST coming in. And what was the thing that Reflex... coming in there are some technologies like
[SPEAKER_01]: this which help the pilot in reducing the collapses but at a lot of times collapse is also a safety mechanism because otherwise there's a chance
[SPEAKER_01]: of falling into the canopy completely so where is the sweet spot and how do you as a designer look for that sweet spot when it comes to letting the
[SPEAKER_01]: wings collapse because the turbulence otherwise will be very dangerous we learn the last 20-30 years about these factors and we are
[SPEAKER_00]: flying with a paraglider need to be collapsed. If the paraglider is not collapsing, then it will be more dangerous, actually. But what's
[SPEAKER_00]: important is after collapse, when the wing is slowly opening or not huge impulsive openings and like pastime, then it's more dangerous. So we
[SPEAKER_00]: learn how to design wings more smooth after collapse, and this is internal structure, and then also the inlets, shapes, and all these are
[SPEAKER_00]: developed last 20 years. So actually the internal structure was developed in a good way, safe, and everything was more easy. Dumped.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, more, the gliders were more dumped, yeah. Okay, a question comes to my mind. Let's say your wing has collapsed 50% or 60%. Your one side of
[SPEAKER_01]: the riser is gone. So now the whole of the tension is on the other side. Is it theoretically possible that if the turbulence of the air mass is very
[SPEAKER_01]: disturbed, it can collapse the flying side as well and your glider can crumple into a small ball? Possible, yes. If there is so much
[SPEAKER_00]: turbulence, then this could happen. But today, if you have such a huge collapse and The wing will not completely destroy, even if in the strong
[SPEAKER_00]: turbulence, if you hold the brakes correctly. And if the wings are opening, radically impulsive opening, then it's more dangerous
[SPEAKER_00]: because then this the very impulsive opening will react, the other side collapse. Then you might go crash. Cascaded. Yeah. I saw that in China
[SPEAKER_00]: last month and during the World Cup, the takeoff was very cliff and very dangerous. So one of Chinese girl flew this photon and then after huge
[SPEAKER_00]: collapse one side and then opening was incredible. Impulsive, violent, and then whole glider just collapsed like this, and then
[SPEAKER_00]: crushed the cliff. Was she okay? She hurt a bit, but I don't know what's happening. But it's air. It happens with modern technology wings. But
[SPEAKER_00]: compared to before, it is now more... Safer at gunpoint. I agree. Don't you think we can have some sort of a slider technology like the skydiving
[SPEAKER_01]: canopies have to reduce the impact of these violent... Why is that not being implemented by paragliding? Slider technology is completely
[SPEAKER_00]: different. You can use it on the parachute, but not paragliding. I just want to add on the wave leading edge. The wave leading edge is the
[SPEAKER_00]: airflow. You read about the wave leading edge. So the airflow, usually when air comes in the leading edge and then right after the leading edge
[SPEAKER_00]: there's separations and they create the turbulence. With the wave leading edge, this separation start quite late so the air is smooth in
[SPEAKER_00]: the leading edge part so the wing has no shooting tendency at all after some situation so we discovered that this wave leading edge is helping
[SPEAKER_00]: really a lot after the huge collapse then the glider reaction is very very slow because this separation stays very bad. If it's here near the
[SPEAKER_00]: leading edge then the glider will shoot. So that's a huge difference with the wave leading edge. So we are keep developing the whole range of
[SPEAKER_00]: the wings with the wave leading edge. That's what I was going to ask, actually. Thank you for bringing us back to the topic. That we see
[SPEAKER_01]: two-liner technology going only from open class to triple C down to E and D, and now even C-class gliders are pretty much only being sold in
[SPEAKER_01]: two-liners, where the money is lying for the manufacturers. Michael Nessler, probably somebody that you know already, he has been a
[SPEAKER_01]: designer for the German brand of SWIFT. Swing. Swing. I beg your pardon. And for anybody who's interested in listening, just scroll up in the
[SPEAKER_01]: index. We have had a very informative podcast with Michael Nestor earlier as well. He's the first one to bring two-liner into E and B class
[SPEAKER_01]: and even get it certified with approval from DHV, the German watchdog. in this. So are we looking at two-liner technologies and new
[SPEAKER_01]: technologies like wave leading edge finally making their way to beginner class gliders as well? Because they do promise safety, but at
[SPEAKER_01]: the same time, they also promise more performance, which eventually translates into more fun for anybody going out and chasing airtime.
[SPEAKER_00]: Currently, the EN rule is if you use the folding lines, With a two-liner, you cannot make a collapse without folding lines. So the Nestle was
[SPEAKER_00]: clever to put one line on the front, which is just hanging, and then that's why they passed E and B. But actually it's not a two-liner. Wave
[SPEAKER_00]: leading edge is different. Wave leading edge, I can use it in all. We, in the beginning, we test in wind tunnel with higher spectra ratio. And now
[SPEAKER_00]: we have now tested in the wind tunnels with a lower spectra ratio. So we have new tubercle shapes for the lower spectra ratio. So we are actually
[SPEAKER_00]: working on the high B 2.5 lines, we say. Wave leading edge wing, which is Explorer 3, is coming. So this one, we know the benefit of wave leading
[SPEAKER_00]: edge. So what's wrong with the low aspect ratio? Mr. Jin, there was a very interesting development before the wave leading edge that I saw on your
[SPEAKER_01]: website. And that was a new fabric. Now fabric industry is mostly dominated by Dominico and Pocher. That is their foster suppliers. A lot
[SPEAKER_01]: of brands use them. A lot of suppliers, pilots are also comfortable with them. But Jin was the first one again to challenge the status quo and
[SPEAKER_01]: bring out a fabric called Muenjin fabric. Yes. Can you please tell us what was this all about and how did that happen? Actually, the Myeongjin
[SPEAKER_00]: is a very old company who used to produce for the military parachute fabrics. The older fabrics today for paraglider today is nylon double
[SPEAKER_00]: six. Everybody knows that. The low material come from DuPont. It's everybody use that one. And... So the parachute industry has been, I
[SPEAKER_00]: don't know how many years, they are using this ripstop technology. Just today, paragliding fabric is, paraglider fabric is how to coat These
[SPEAKER_00]: are the raw materials. That's the technology. So it's just the coating which is actually being researched upon? Not only the coating, also how
[SPEAKER_00]: to weave the ribs and things like this. So they design to make it light and strong enough and also air porosity. So they... In the beginning,
[SPEAKER_00]: Myeongjin didn't want to take any risk. So they are okay to make a bottom surface fabric and then profile fabric in the beginning. But they are
[SPEAKER_00]: afraid to use the fabric on top surface because of air porosity and so on. So we think encourage them to develop it. And then, so they were, yeah, we
[SPEAKER_00]: spent some money. Jingle had to pay them to develop the fabrics. So finally they made the fabric and then we made the, test the wings. For
[SPEAKER_00]: example, the one school glider and one tandem gliders. And we send it to one in France and one in very like a desert, rough condition. The ground
[SPEAKER_00]: is not grass and things like this. Then we get the wing back and check the porosity, strength again. Then we test again as it took some years to
[SPEAKER_00]: reach the fabrics on top. And then we were sure that this is because we've done enough tests. So the Myungjin start to coming in the market. And we
[SPEAKER_00]: make a special contract when we spend money because we pay the development. So when the fabric comes and only we use two years
[SPEAKER_00]: exclusively, then they cancel after two years. So we are still doing... The light fabric we are working, like 21 grams or whatever. So we have a
[SPEAKER_00]: special contract and because we test everything for them. So they, Myeongjin and Jingle Light is quite close. So then after Myeongjin,
[SPEAKER_00]: when Jingle Light was using Myeongjin, then everybody contacted Myeongjin. So many other brands now using the Myeongjin too. How is it
[SPEAKER_01]: different or better than the other offerings? We have very strong relations. And then also the guy, his father was a very good engineer.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then his son is now... take over the jobs and then he's very clever and then he is quite listen to us. So when I ask him to develop this and they're
[SPEAKER_00]: really coming to do. So a lot of the brand like Dominico is hardly order them to what to do. They have their rules and they just that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dominico is impossible to communicate for me. So, Myeongjin is the same country, so... Like a household, right? Yeah, that's why we can develop
[SPEAKER_00]: the one which we want. So, this is very good for us. Do things like... I see you're doing a lot of in-house things, let's say, with the Jin Lab
[SPEAKER_01]: opening up. Are you willing to open up this at a certain stage later on? Of course, at the royalties being paid out, so that eventually, in future,
[SPEAKER_01]: other brands can try and benefit from these technologies. Yeah, I'm okay to do that, because there is certainly the benefit, Wave Leading
[SPEAKER_00]: Edge is helping for the safety and whatever, so we actually have a patent on it, but if anyone can use Wave Leading Edge, but we wait until some
[SPEAKER_00]: years, for sure. You wait until at least half of the podium is, or the complete podium is filled with boomerangs once again, the good old
[SPEAKER_01]: times. I hope so, yeah. Why not? Why not? Mr. Jin, I see that you have been one of the industry leaders in a lot of, you know, tech. Timer kites are
[SPEAKER_01]: coming out with all their force. What do you think about this new technology, this new way of having fun? Actually, the Tim Bollinger is
[SPEAKER_00]: working on it. Right. He likes to play these things, so we are using the kite, one of the kites from Hans Bollinger. And then his father, Tim
[SPEAKER_00]: Bollinger. So Tim is using the kite and we modified this kite and he's now testing this one. Yes. But I don't know. This is already, the Skywalk has
[SPEAKER_00]: a huge market for that. So... We are not very interested in coming because first we want to take over the SRS and then World Cup. My first
[SPEAKER_00]: priority. And then we also, in the same time, we should make a very good school gliders and intermediate, which is the most selling part. And
[SPEAKER_00]: then also the tandem is a huge market for jean gliders. So we are the leader in the tandem business in the market. I think you must have
[SPEAKER_01]: definitely seen the BB, what was it? Golden? What is the name of the brand? Gradient. Gradient, yeah. What was it about that wing that made
[SPEAKER_01]: it so famous in tandem? I don't know. It was light and an easy takeoff. easy to flare that's all for the tandem is what all you need is that but
[SPEAKER_00]: today the fuse four our fuse one two three four is the huge portion in the market So I think we are the leader in the tandem business now. And then
[SPEAKER_00]: now Gradient, I don't know. It shut down. It shut down and the super bought it. And after that, they are quiet. I think the car riding
[SPEAKER_01]: industry is a pretty brutal market. And that is what inspires me about you, that you have not only stayed relevant, but you have stayed
[SPEAKER_01]: competitive and are still challenging. Yeah, yeah. Which brings me to one of the final topics of our talk, because we'll be running out of time
[SPEAKER_01]: very soon. Boom 13. First of all, the color looks fantastic. Thank you. I was gliding with you the other day, and I was like, oh, that wing. I could
[SPEAKER_01]: definitely look at that for a while, but then you zoomed past pretty effortlessly. We are in two very different classes anyways. Please
[SPEAKER_01]: tell us about Boom 13, without letting out any secrets. Oh, yeah, it's been... I started to develop this boomerang after boomerang 12 with a
[SPEAKER_00]: wave leading edge. It was very successful. We won one World Cup, fourth, second, third, with a wave leading edge boom 12. Clean sweep. Clean
[SPEAKER_01]: sweep of the point. Yes. That was a very big success. And then Ozone came with the submarines. Yes. So they win again. Okay. So then I start to make
[SPEAKER_00]: the wings. It took some time to come with the Boom 13. Yeah, today, what you need is the competition is almost full speed. You never go trim
[SPEAKER_00]: speed. You almost never go, honestly. I think I'll be surprised even in thermals, people are, how late they are letting off the bar. Yeah, this
[SPEAKER_00]: is a really incredible competition. So... This is the key of the winning wings. How fast you can go and then how much better glide in full speed.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the big things. So we did actually the little wind tunnel test and then we work a lot for the wing tips. Yeah, I think now quite good. We will
[SPEAKER_00]: see after this competition. Do you have an approximate date in your mind when you think you will be able to finish the product and bring it home? Oh
[SPEAKER_00]: no, it's done, finished. Oh, beautiful. Yeah, the certification is done and we are certified six days before the World Championship
[SPEAKER_00]: starts. So we are definitely, we will send this wing for the World Championship. So here is the only one glider I fly when I have a better
[SPEAKER_00]: result.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm an old man and my goal is to show my wings during the thermalings and kind of things. Yesterday I was climbing better than a few guys in the
[SPEAKER_00]: gaggle, so I was happy. I think you flying a triple C on full bar at this stage itself is quite a humble brag to say the least. Yeah, like an old man
[SPEAKER_00]: like me. Don't call yourself old, sir. I think you're young at heart, and that is what really matters. I forgot to talk about Carrera, because
[SPEAKER_01]: Carrera has a B-class certification, but a very nice handling. Could you tell us a little bit about that? Because obviously there are a lot of
[SPEAKER_01]: market players, pilots who are interested in things of that certification. Carrera was designed for C-class initially, but then
[SPEAKER_00]: during the EN test, the test house say, you have no C, it's completely CB.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was a welcome surprise. Yeah, it was a surprise then. I said, okay, then we take it as B. Because in the marketing, I discussed with my
[SPEAKER_00]: marketing teams, and B market is for sure much bigger than C market. And no one has a spectra ratio of 6. on the B glider. And so I said, okay, let's
[SPEAKER_00]: see how it goes. So we launched and yeah, the Carrera was just boom, like crazy. It was big success. And today the biggest market is the B class
[SPEAKER_00]: market. Yes. So we are now making two different B, low B and high B. It's coming before Cupica. Wow. So I'm pretty busy to finish this one. I can
[SPEAKER_01]: imagine. And I'm very thankful that you gave me an hour- long conversation out of your busy schedule because I've been chasing you
[SPEAKER_01]: for more than a year now. And finally, it was such a welcome surprise when I bumped into you at this World Cup. I was like, yes! Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mr. Jim, before I let you go, we have a tradition on our show where I ask my guests to share one flight that has remained with them throughout their
[SPEAKER_01]: flying career so far. And with almost five decades of Shazang airtime, I know it's going to be hard, but if you can share one flight, the memory of
[SPEAKER_01]: one flight with our audiences, I'll be very thankful. Memorial. Memory of one flight, how it went or what was, if you remember anything. My best
[SPEAKER_00]: memory was during the World Championship in Switzerland, Velbier. I was flying alone, somehow. What year? 1993, in Switzerland. That was
[SPEAKER_00]: during the World Championship. Somehow I was leading and alone, so I was low in the valley. It was almost like very steep mountains, so I was like
[SPEAKER_00]: soaring up. And then I met the day, how you call it, the year. Deer with the beak. Okay, so the animal deer with big horns. Antlers and stuff like
[SPEAKER_01]: that. Yes, big one. So I thought maybe this is a male and then must be some females. And I looked down, there's a female was climbing. Such a stiff.
[SPEAKER_00]: So when I make one soaring, I went to the other side, but when I come back in, this animal was there. Wow. And then it was just the feeling, it
[SPEAKER_00]: touches my heart. The animal was look my eyes and eye contact. And this feeling was amazing. You can't explain the feeling with nature. how
[SPEAKER_00]: beautiful paragliding is. This is amazing. And one more I can say is, it was in Russia, Kurai Valley, there's a competition, and we flew there
[SPEAKER_00]: with the huge eagles, like big vulture, almost two and a half meters wingspan. I was flying with this vulture, And somehow my direction was
[SPEAKER_00]: to go to the west, but this vulture was flying a little bit different direction. I followed this vulture, and then actually I did a faster
[SPEAKER_00]: goal than I was straight. And then with the vulture, we circling together, and then I was afraid that if the vulture is attack, like
[SPEAKER_00]: Australia, They whipped the wings and kind of things. But this vulture was very gentle and flying, so find the thermal for me. This kind of
[SPEAKER_00]: nature feeling, this is the beauty of the paragliding. I can totally relate to this because it happened to me once in my early days in flying.
[SPEAKER_01]: In beer building, we have Griffin vultures, massive, as you said, two, three meters. I was still learning to thermal. And I had this vulture
[SPEAKER_01]: circle super tight, and I would never bury my break so hard and take a circle so tight because I thought I would stall the wing. But I was like,
[SPEAKER_01]: no, if he's circling, then he's in the core, then I can trust him. And I did that, and within two or three circles, we gained a lot. And I just started
[SPEAKER_01]: screaming. And then the virtual looks me in the eye and that eye contact. Yeah, this is, oh. Eye contact with wildlife out in the nature is
[SPEAKER_01]: magical. Magic, that's it. Completely agree. This is magic and touches your heart. 100%. That visual has stuck with me until now as well. I
[SPEAKER_01]: usually say this with a lot of guests that have quite a few experience that there's no one single episode that will do justice to the amount of
[SPEAKER_01]: knowledge that you can share. But for now, we have come to an end of this episode. So heartfelt thanks for being on the show. It means the world to
[SPEAKER_01]: me, and I'm sure the audiences can relate to the same as well. We wish you all the very luck and simply cannot wait for you to bring out your
[SPEAKER_01]: awesomeness to the audiences. Thank you very much. Thank you. Hey everyone, for those of you who have listened this far, I just wanted to
[SPEAKER_01]: drop in a note of thanks because you guys are the ones who are actually making the difference. It means the world to me whenever I see audience
[SPEAKER_01]: retention rates remain high all the way to the end. And I'd like to add on by saying that if you have liked the content that you just consumed, do
[SPEAKER_01]: consider liking, subscribing, and dropping a rating wherever possible, because that is one way we can let the algorithms of all of
[SPEAKER_01]: these streaming platforms know that this episode is worthy of being pushed out to more pilots in the community. So collectively, you and I
[SPEAKER_01]: can make this sport a safer and a more fun place to be. Well, on that note, thank you once again for joining me today. And I'm really looking
[SPEAKER_01]: forward to connecting with you in the next episode as well. Until then, I'm going to say what I always say, and that is stay tuned, stay excited,
[SPEAKER_01]: because this magic is just getting started.